[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions it's the Ramsey show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships I'm your host Dave Ramsey
Jade wash all Ramsay personality is my
co-host open phones for you to call in
and talk about your life we'll talk
about you right in front of you the
phone number is triple eight eight two
five five two two five you jump in and
we'll talk Tristan's going to start this
hour in Indianapolis hi Tristan how are
you
I'm great how are you Dave better than I
deserve what's up
um so I'm calling to get some advice on
our situation I'm a stay-at-home mom my
husband's a full-time nurse making 80
000 a year we have about a hundred and
forty thousand and just various debts to
get paid off our house we have about 173
000 left on our house if we were to sell
today in the market we can make about a
hundred thousand I guess my question is
should we do that to pay off some of
this debt you got a hundred and
forty thousand how much was it in debt
yeah about 140 000 and we have two cars
yeah how much of that give me your car
breakdown
um my husband's car is like 88 800 and
my car is at like eleven thousand
okay and what's the rest of this mess
um we got one credit card at like a
thousand we have another credit card at
like nine thousand
thousand um and then we have student
loans and we have a
a smaller loan that's like 11 or 12 000
that helps fix our crawl space
the student loans are the big chunk
Yes Yes mine especially how much is it
um it's about 80.
and how many kids do you guys have we
have three how old are they sorry I know
that's rapid fire no you can't uh we
have an eight-year-old a five-year-old
and a one and a half year old
if it's me I have a couple questions
okay he's a nurse he's making eighty
thousand is were you working before kids
or have you always been a stay-at-home
mom
um I've worked here and there I worked
briefly
um when my oldest was little and then
once we had my second
um my paycheck essentially just would
pay for child care and it just wasn't
worth it for us so what was your career
um I mean just customer service type
gigs I worked at a gym front desk type
things you have a degree
I don't okay and your husband's a nurse
okay is there anything that you can I
let me rephrase that question I think
that there are things that you can also
do to earn money from home when you have
time because at the end of the day the
equation here is we've got to get the
income up I wouldn't sell the house to
get a hundred thousand dollars if that
was your initial question
um I think that you guys need to work
through this and I know that you can
work through this 140 000 80 000 income
if you can find twenty thousand dollars
if you can find twenty five thousand
dollars a year anything is going to help
this equation move faster
right right because at this point
uprooting the family doing all this to
get a hundred thousand dollars you're
gonna have to then save up three to six
months and then you're gonna save up a
down payment and whatever you move over
to to rent is not going to be a big
difference as a matter of fact you could
end up spending more money monthly yeah
if I were in your shoes I would go
through three years of Hell rather than
sell your house
okay and the three years of Hell sounds
like this he picks up side gigs in the
ER and you find something you do to work
from home and those two things together
add forty or fifty thousand dollars to
this equation and you throw all of that
and some more uh towards this student
loan and you're done in two to three
years but you're gonna not see each
other you're gonna be tired
um you're definitely not going out to
eat you're not going on vacation you're
going to sell so much stuff around the
house that that the kids think they're
next uh I mean you're gonna your friends
are gonna be making fun of you because
you're joined a cult I mean it's you're
going to be having all of this kind of
thing going on for about two and a half
to three years and then you'll be free
forever and let me raise my hand on
something here Tristan the kids are
eight five and one and a half it may
have made more sense
several two even two years ago to stay
at home because he had two kids outside
of kindergarten that were younger right
and now you've got a kindergartner
you've got an eight-year-old you've only
got the one kid at home so if you found
the right gig it might do you see what
I'm saying it could be worth it to
re-crunch those numbers because that
does happen could be worth it to bring
three kids into your home and keep them
and that's your gig
oh okay you know because people are
looking for uh inexpensive child care
now that's kind of cool too if you're I
don't know I don't know what the rules
are in Indianapolis how many kids before
you leave being a babysitter and become
a daycare but
um you don't want to get into that but
uh from a reg's regulation standpoint
and all that but anyway
you know uh people have kept other
people's children's in their home for
Generations
um and paid for it and so yeah that's
something I would consider and that's
kind of becomes a no-brainer I don't
know but and this is not you know none
of this is pleasant but selling your
home's not pleasant being in debt's not
pleasant you know nothing here there's
no Pleasant on the table for the next
two years that's true so let's just
choose our pain choose our hard and lean
into it and go at least there's an end
to the one we're describing and the end
is you know you're going to call in here
you guys are going to bring the three
kids on the show and we're going to do a
debt free Scream by God you know that's
what we're gonna do that's right we're
gonna get fired up and wired up here and
that's that's what we want for you and
we'll help you we're going to put you
into Financial Peace University our nine
week program and that'll also sign you
up for every dollar the budgeting app
and um we'll show you how to do this
stuff that people are doing all the time
they've been doing it for you know 30
years I've been teaching this stuff and
be sure to to tune into our student loan
live stream that's coming up on the 12th
and I mean your big portion of this debt
is student loans and you're not alone in
that there's so many people who are
facing that and that live stream is
going to help them figure out how to
budget figure out what their payment is
figure out how to pay these things off
for good so that they're no longer
haunted by the ghost of of education's
past
and ruled by the uh well anyway we'll
just yeah we'll deal with that later
yeah so hang on uh we'll have Austin
pick up get you signed up for Financial
Peace University and get you going in
that because that's what you're gonna
have to do Tristan what we're describing
I understand it's almost bizarre it's so
weird but so is being free
being completely free of dad in America
today is so weird that it's bizarre yeah
so if you're going to have unusual
results unreasonable results you're
going to have to engage in unreasonable
behaviors and you know the lady sitting
beside me did it for seven years and Sam
yeah you work like 17 different things I
mean yeah and had little kids while
you're doing it well we the kids came
after this oh I'm sorry but I will say
you have to embrace the things that no
one else is willing to embrace you have
to do those things that people will look
at you and go wow they're weird yeah
like they're crazy they sold the
furniture in their house they're crazy
yeah that's nuts I mean they just sold
they haven't been on vacation in two
years yeah I don't know how do you make
it yeah they they go to the restaurant
and they just order water they're
they're just there for for the social
aspect they're not there to to go out to
eat to eat they're not there for food
that's right at a restaurant yeah that's
weird that is weird I'm happy to be
weird Dave I like it going out for
drinks with my friends more water yes
I'll take the water please
water
[Laughter]
is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
folks you know that sinking feeling when
you make an offer on a house you love
and then you hear there's another offer
you need the Churchill Mortgage home
buyer Edge super fast pre-approval and a
secured interest rate plus a five
thousand dollar seller guarantee gives
your offer the best chance of being
accepted the home buyer Edge from
Churchill gives you an advantage over
those other guys go to
churchillmortgage.com today to learn
more
[Music]
thank you
Jade wash all Ramsay personality is my
co-host today I'm Dave Ramsey your host
I didn't think it was possible with the
Epic student loan debacle
for it to get any Dumber out there but
it has it's not good Dave
student loan repayment four million
people have enrolled in Biden's save
plan ahead of the payment restart
according to cnn.com yes now we know a
lot of these people were probably
automatically enrolled it says the
majority of them so basically CNN's
headline is a lie yeah four million
people enrolled in Biden's save plan
ahead of payment restart no they didn't
the vast majority of them were
automatically defaulting default
enrolled they didn't voluntarily enroll
they didn't actively enroll so they
didn't enroll that's right you pushed
them in like cattle pushed them in
that's not enrolling
and so the majority of them came out of
the other program that failed called
repay and now we're into save because we
have to have acronyms in Washington for
our stupidity right it makes it sound
better than what it is because what it
is is a trap God this thing is awful it
says launched earlier this summer The
save plan save they call it saving on a
valuable education that's laughable it's
available available to most people with
federal student loans and this is what
they're saying it can provide an air
quote significant relief to borrowers
struggling to pay off their student debt
I would not be struggling to pay off
it'd be struggling to pay yeah it does
it does do that yeah okay so basically
if you sign up or accidentally were
enrolled even though you didn't enroll
in the new save plan and you're one of
those four million lost souls here's
what you're signed up for uh you have a
formula based on the poverty level that
dictates the dollar amount per month
that you are to pay
if it does not cover the interest being
charged on your student loan the
interest does not accrue
however one hundred percent so in other
words if the interest on your student
loans fifty dollars a month and the
formula says you only have to pay thirty
dollars a month you don't have any extra
interest at it on they forgive the
twenty dollars but what they fail to
mention is one hundred percent of the
thirty dollars goes to interest
consequently what is happening to your
student loan balance
here's what I want not moving it's
sitting there doofus sitting there like
a frog on a log
my God how dumb are you people in
Washington let's sign up people forgive
a portion of their interest allow them
to pay a tiny little payment with the
promise of debt forgiveness uh which you
always lie about up there I mean
perpetually lie about up there when are
you people gonna wake up oh my God it's
dumb this is ridiculous it's ridiculous
and here's my thing I'm like okay the
interest they say it's not going to
accumulate or that it will be forgiven
at the end of your term which by the way
the term starts if you let's say you
have 12 000 just 12 000 Dave okay in
student loans okay the Forgiveness
starts at 10 years of payments
so they want you to keep a twelve
thousand dollar debt no it's 20 years of
payments they're proposing to bring it
back to 10. the proposal has not gone
through right now let me show you here
Biden proposed counseling up to twenty
thousand dollars unlike one-time Council
yeah they're unlike one-time
cancellation proposal is to say plan
committed fit both current and future
borrowers which the new people that are
getting the student loan debt can sign
up for this ridiculous moronic thing
also the Biden Administration first said
it was developing a new repayment plan
last August save is expected to cost
over no that's not the one limit this
isn't where's this this is not the
article this is different so what it is
is if you have you you get in at twelve
thousand twelve thousand dollars equals
ten years of payments and for every
additional thousand Dave that you owe so
13. oh you're paying for 11 years yeah
14 000 you're paying for 12 years
Max is after 20 years they promised to
forgive whatever's left exactly so after
you've done nothing for 20 years it's
going to be forgiven but let me help you
with the people that got promised that
10 years ago right that they were going
to have their loans forgiven for doing
for working for non-profits and in
underserved areas okay you remember
those people yeah yeah
000 people have applied for that
you know how many got it
1.6
so after 20 years of doing basically
nothing hoping you're going to get
forgiveness
1.6 percent of you so bad this is this
is basically the DMV of the financial
world this is the dumbest butt thing the
most inefficient socialistic garbage
I've ever seen in my life Kick the Can
down the road put your hands over yours
and go la la la la la la la la this is
not happening dumb butt idea now have I
been unclear
I hope I hadn't been unclear so how are
you going to get out of student loan
this is what you need to do guys it's
ten thousand dollars in debt deliver
pizza so easy like and make two thousand
dollars a month delivering pizzas every
night and you're done in six months yeah
and you have the rest of your life
to not be screwing around with people
like the Biden Administration oh my God
gosh yeah it's unbelievable it's
unbelievable this is ridiculous
and CNN is so stupid and you know half
the media will pick the same this this
press release by the way this headline
came from the White House yeah it did
and they republished it because it's a
lot student loan repayment four million
people enrolled enroll in Biden save
plan had nobody enrolled you
automatically to defend to it yeah I
mean the number of people that
physically signed up for this idiocy on
purpose is very small
but they're making it well four million
people did it you should too yeah no you
shouldn't
good good Lord people when are you gonna
get a clue that the White House and the
people in Washington DC are not here to
bless you these people are what you know
what this doesn't keep you in debt your
whole freaking life
you're 35 years old you're 55 with
grandkids and you're still screwing
around with your college
you ought to have unbelievably naive at
best stupid at worst to believe the lies
they peddle out of the Republicans or
the Democrats regarding student loans
because let me just tell you student
loans are awful they're horrible then
why do you morons keep making them now
there's a question Dave there's a
there's a dadgum
us intellectually dishonest bunch of
people yeah you know we're going to do
everything we can to forgive your
student loans and make it easy because
there's such a burden on you while we
continue to make them to the Next
Generation you can't solve a problem
you're a freshman in high in college
right now they're going to put you 100
Grand in debt let you get a degree in
left-handed puppetry and then put you on
thirty dollars a month for the next 25
years and then lie to you about whether
we're going to forgive it at the end of
that please people don't be so stupid
this is ridiculous it's completely out
of control this I mean I read this I got
I
you know I don't know why I got pissed
off because I should expect this kind of
stupidity out of Washington yeah and I
should expect this kind of stupidity out
of the press where they put a headline
that is completely false across the stop
top I mean this is oh jeez so we're
gonna we're gonna help you with that
listen your student loan interest has
restarted it started last week okay your
payments are going to start October 1st
you know when that's going to be here
faster than Christmas it's going to be
here in a minute okay a hot minute
you're gonna have to start paying
payments again and if you're dumb enough
to sign up for a 30 a month plan and
stay in debt the rest of your life I can
help you
you're just too dumb to be helped okay
that's not gonna work I can't help you
you got no more you got the motivation
of a dead brick oh come on seriously I
can help you though Jade can help you if
you will get up off your assets and go
do something about this that's right you
guys got to sign up for our student loan
it's student loans in America how we got
here how we're getting out it's a free
live stream if you have student loans
and you are not signing up for this free
live stream there's something wrong with
you and I can't help you if you want
help sign up for the live stream we're
going to tell you everything you need to
do we're going to help you hey let's
charge 30 a month for 20 years for this
oh love that I mean that would make it
popular and four million people could
accidentally sign up for it
isn't that funny Dave how when we want
to do something to set people free that
sounds asinine yeah well it sounds like
you you people are taking advantage of
poor people by giving you a free live
stream yeah would you shut up seriously
it's free
figure out how that's manipulative okay
that's free yeah Jade is going to show
you we're gonna I know some of you are
scared okay well then do something about
it I know some of you are confused good
do something about it I'll show you how
I've been doing this for 30 years and it
ain't gonna be you screw around with
this for the rest of your life I can
promise you this spoiler alert you're
gonna get with it you're gonna get a
callous on your working hand baby this
is what you're gonna do you're gonna go
and don't worry about working too hard
just before you die you'll pass out it's
okay we're gonna teach you how to do
this stuff sign up student loan live
stream
ramseysolutions.com student loans
thank you
foreign
[Music]
well you've all played the telephone
game the first person Whispers a message
to the second person who Whispers it to
the third and so on around the table
until the original message has
completely changed multiply that
confusion by a hundred if you run a
business with different software systems
that don't talk to each other that's why
there's netsuite by Oracle in the early
days of Ramsey we were using different
systems for all of our business units we
needed one single source for accurate
data netsuite was the software we used
to optimize and take us to the next
level netsuite gave us the visibility
into all of our numbers so that we could
communicate across departments and plan
ahead better and as we grew it scaled
with us netsuite worked for Ramsay and
it will make a difference for your
business too join the more than 34 000
customers who trust netsuite to help
make them smarter and make better
decisions and level up their operations
to learn more get a free product tour at
netsuite.com Ramsay that's netsuite.com
Ramsay
foreign
[Music]
personality is my co-host today thank
you for joining us America Jake is with
us in Dayton Ohio hi Jake how are you
hey thanks for taking my call good how
can we help
um so World got a little flipped upside
down
um
I got a injury
I'm 26 and uh they said that I'm gonna
need a total knee replacement
and
it's not going to affect my career now
however in the next 10 to 15 years I'll
need a second knee replacement
and based off of that they said a decent
chance that I would not be able to go
back to work
that's at that job
yeah in this career field so I'm uh I'm
in law enforcement so okay my thought
process I'm trying to figure out is
do I go ahead and switch careers now
because I I don't want to you know keep
dumping money into a pension and then be
40 with kids and then have to switch
careers and take a takea because
everything I'm looking at right now is a
significant pay cut to where I'm at
okay well let's just change the set of
assumptions
uh what do you make
last year with overtime I made 102. okay
all right
so
the assumption that you can't make 102
ever again in your life is not a correct
assumption
no sir yeah I get that it's just
everything I'm looking at right now I
know but yeah but right now your heart's
kind of broken because you've been had
your height your your sights set on
being in law enforcement your whole life
or a large portion of your life and
you're heavily invested and then you got
injured and you've gone through the
trauma the emotional trauma of the
injury and the physical trauma and now
they're telling you that that you know
your dream's gonna die early
right and so in that mindset you usually
don't see this the sunlight you usually
see the storm clouds
that would be in human nature not that
you're a bad guy okay but I'm not
sitting in all that mess that you've
been through and so for me I'm got 26
year old guy who's bright enough to
become a police officer he's bright
enough to become a lot of things
between now and 10 years from now
I mean you could open a business and
make 2 million a year I don't know
how old are you uh 26. I'm 26. and I
since I found this out uh I signed up
for classes again and me and my wife are
cash flowing that good but I'm just
trying to yeah I just don't know like
how long is too long to stay in this
career based off of you know like when
when's the best time to switch careers
well number one you don't want to get
injured again
um or or you know leave your partner in
trouble because of an injury or
something like that
um and number two you don't want to uh
you know wear it all the way down but do
we have to decide this week no we don't
set this week I mean we have to go work
at Chick-fil-A no crap no that's not
what you're doing okay you but you know
what I would do is say okay over the
next two to three years I'm gonna
develop a my next my Encore career my
next career after the curtain goes down
and comes back up and I'm Gonna Get You
know what classes I have to take or
certifications I have to take to be that
and I'm going to become a student of Ken
Coleman and and go live my next dream
which
oddly enough might end up better
now I like that that's interesting yeah
yeah that's thinking God's making me
making me change a career here so I'm
just trying to figure out well what what
what kind of timeline is here you know
yeah maybe or or you know um you know my
whole life was set up for me to be a
real estate investor
and then my real estate portfolio is
deeply in debt and I lost everything and
I was 28 years old just a tiny bit older
than you with a brand new baby and a
toddler and um and went bankrupt and
lost everything and so um I get to have
a new career after that because guess
what they don't loan you a bunch of
money at the bank to go do flips if you
just file bankruptcy so that was kind of
out and so those days were over plus I
was done with them because it didn't
bring me a lot of fun and so and but the
time your knee got busted you know
you're you're part you're partially over
being a policeman at that point because
you're like this this is less fun than I
thought it was going to be yeah you know
and so you're having a little bit of
that same kind of an experience and you
get this next chapter of your life this
uh second half so to speak and I yeah
you know I think about things like that
even what you just said Dave you did
this I was just about to say I came from
entertainment I was an Entertainer my
entire life and then covet happened and
there was no entertainment and I had to
contemplate my life and I realized being
entertaining that's how low we got but I
realized hey there's other things I can
do there's other things I'm good at and
I think that you'll find the same thing
and I'm the type of person where I think
we just go from from good to better to
best like if you if you're living your
life right it's just getting better and
better and I think that this has the
opportunity to take you on yet another
adventure that's going to have another
great outcome you know being a law
enforcement officer is going to be the
first part and then you're going to move
on to something else and then who knows
you might move on to something else but
that's just the evolution of life and
it's not a failure it's not an it
doesn't have to be a negative this can
be a this can be one of the greatest
things that's ever happened to you
because it'll open that that next door
you don't know what's going to be behind
it but you got to keep turning those
knobs and something's going to be behind
there and you're going to look back on
this and go man here's what my prayer
always is
I want to look back and go man I'm so
grateful XYZ happened
because when that happened it allowed me
to do this this and that and this has
the potential to do that for you you'll
look at this right now it's painful it
sucks but in a couple of years in eight
years in 12 years
yes you know I never would have been at
Ramsey if it wasn't for 2020 yeah yeah
and everybody hated 2020. thank you
thank you fauci that's the only time
we'll say it that's the only time that's
the only time you ever hear that
nobody nobody except the Plexiglas
people say thank you falci I'm just
saying now that's what it means to get
fouchied then
so yeah that's the thing anyway but I
mean yeah the point is I mean I I didn't
I didn't sign up for bankruptcy it
wasn't what I wanted no uh and I I won't
say it's the worst it's the worst thing
that ever happened to me and it's the
best thing I've ever done I agree both
yeah very dramatic traumatic uh and I I
you know I I still you know we've got
the actual bankruptcy filing on the wall
when I file bankruptcy out here in the
in the Ramsey Lobby when you come out
here just so you can see how this
started and I walked by that I still
kind of go yeah you know it's like oh
crud you know but and it's been 30 years
and I still get the heebie-jeebies but
yeah but so it's not like I'm still
joyful about the whole thing but you
know I never would have sold 10 million
books Selling Houses yeah I feel that I
I thank God that we went through that
460 000 of debt so just checked at the
time I'm gonna sign you up for Ken
Coleman's uh career assessment and it
takes about 15 minutes to take I'm going
to give it to you free and I want you to
take that and it's going to kind of
point you in some directions that you
probably were already thinking about but
it'll start to give you some clarity on
that and I'm also going to send you his
book from paycheck to purpose because I
think what you've got here is not the
end of the play I think you've got the
second act
we're between the First Act and the
second act and
um there's no rush you said you've got
10 years before this is going to go
sideways on you so to speak and
um but so I mean we can take two or we
can take six months and figure this out
we do want to actively figure it out
though we don't want to sit and let this
situation happen to you that's right you
want to happen to it be proactive but
let's determine you know okay here's the
direction and then and let me tell you
what the direction is Jake the direction
is not go back to school
that's a good point that isn't people
get this I just go back to school for
what because if you don't know because
that's just I just go back to school no
that's Dumber in a rock you may be
studying exactly the wrong thing and you
may not even need to go to school for
what you're thinking about doing so um
when we talked to a guy the other day
he's making 300 000 a year and he has a
landscaping business he cuts grass yeah
you know yes shut up yeah do not go back
to school unless you know you've done
your research and you're locked in you
have to have it yeah you definitely
don't go into debt for it no but you
have to have them you have to have the
degree or the knowledge base to open up
the fee you know it's permission to play
in the field you're going into right
okay and so you know what we got to do
there uh and you know it could be as
simple as I may not be appealing to you
could be as simple as you work on your
Master's level stuff and uh admit in Law
Enforcement Administration and you move
up into leadership and you know where
the knee is not the problem and that
changes the whole discussion I don't
know maybe maybe you're but maybe your
law of a law enforcement parlays you up
into that it's okay to be either any of
those but do it intentionally take two
to three years to get tooled up begin to
make your move gradually so you sneak up
on this it doesn't sneak up on you and
we'll send you the tools from Ken
Coleman to help you do that this is the
Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
hey if you're in over your head with
student loans and tired of getting calls
from collection agencies if private
student loan debt is taking away your
financial piece and you don't see any
way out you need why refi they're not a
debt settlement company and they're not
connected to a bank why refi refinances
defaulted private student loans that
other places won't touch and gives you a
custom loan built for you based on your
ability to pay so when you refinance
your private student loan debt with why
refi you'll have a payment you can
afford with a low fixed interest rate
you couldn't get anywhere else to help
you stick to your budget and work the
debt snowball and you can save thousands
of dollars to learn more about this
custom refinancing option and a lump sum
payoff option you could qualify for
after 24 months call
8442 Ramsey or go to
yrefi.com Ramsay
[Music]
thanks for joining us America Jade
warshaw Ramsay personality is my co-host
today Jim is with us in Nashville hey
Jim welcome to the Ramsay show how can
we help
hey Dave glad to talk to you you too man
enjoy your show thank you all right
um I am calling in response to a video I
saw recently that you claimed infinite
banking concept was a scam and actually
got quite pissed off about it so um I um
do not agree with that in certain points
that you made in that um video and I
have set up a policy for my son when he
was one years old he's five now I'm
sorry um
say that again I said I'm sorry
okay
[Laughter]
uh so I set that policy up for when I
was one years old
um it has a 500 000 face value we pay 5
373 a year for 13 years and it's paid up
at that point
um there's a few points that I wanted to
discuss that I just didn't agree with
um do you want to just kind of take one
thing at a time that's fine sure okay
um one of the main things was that you
claimed that uh the cash value dies with
you and you only get
um the face value uh paid out that's
true that is well it's not true if you
reinvest the dividends back into the
policy dividend reinvestment is not cash
value
dividend reinvestment is because you
have a mutual company and the
policyholders are the owners of the
company and so the profits from the
company come to the policyholder and
they use that to buy paid up additions
that is not the same as keeping your
cash value that's buying extra insurance
with your overpayment
but it still works out to be no
um having a cash value much greater than
the 69
849 we put into it but the actual cash
value not the paid up additions the
actual cash value dies with you
no because I think okay but but your
your death benefit is larger than your
cash value so it so whoever you're so
for me I looked at it because you bought
more insurance
you don't want a paid up addition is a
paid up addition is buying additional
insurance
that's why they're getting more at death
not because you got your cash value but
because you used your policy dividends
to buy additional insurance right but
that's different than getting your cash
value if you if you took those policy
dividends and went and bought a term
insurance policy for a hundred thousand
well you'd get a hundred thousand but
that's not your cash value
well I have a Term Policy no way but you
missed my point okay let you're talking
about you use the policy dividends you
use the money they send to you because
you're in a mutual company to buy
additional Insurance yes pay the
petitions yeah yeah if you buy a term
policy on the side for a hundred
thousand dollars instead with that same
money you would get a hundred thousand
dollars more than your face value but
that's not your cash value that's
additional Insurance they're different
but in right they are different in term
you can't you don't have cash value to
borrow again I'm aware of that but your
point was that you don't lose the cash
value and my point is 100 of the time by
definition you lose the cash value okay
but okay so as I said tip for Tat if he
lives to be 80 I'm looking at the uh the
um
readout here if you say he only lives to
be 80. okay all right the cash value
will be worth about two million dollars
but the payout for the death benefit
will be 2.6 million so okay technically
so you take the cash you take you're
taking your bent your policy dividends
and go buy term insurance with it and
you would have more than you're talking
about because you get a better buy on
the insurance than you're getting with
this ripoff whole life crap yes you
would get a high but you wouldn't be
able to use it throughout your life as a
as your own bank I think that's okay but
here's the thing the big thing that's a
side issue that's a side issue but your
first issue was you know he's going to
have all this money at retirement well
let's just do a little present value
calculation on what you put in for a
baby five thousand dollars a year for 13
years do you know what that would be in
a mutual fund
instead of putting it into this rip-off
thing and making four percent on your
money and when he dies he loses his cash
value if you put this in a good mutual
fund you'd have a hundred X 10x the
amount of money and that's your infinite
freaking bank but I we're only putting
in seventy thousand and he's going to be
that's how present value formula Works
in finance you know
let's intellectually deal with this for
a second okay take the same amount of
money when you get off the air and put
it in a financial calculator at 11
percent
and pretend it was invested in mutual
funds and see what it is when he's 88
years old it'll be more a whole lot more
but and he'll have that too with this to
me is a way to no he doesn't have to be
able to to borrow against that's what
you that's called opportunity cost on
your money you put it into something
that's going to make him at 88 have two
and a half million and he should have
had 25 million because you screwed up
and put it in the wrong thing well we
when we screwed up and put it in real
estate too and he's going to get real
estate but then put the money in real
estate but don't put it in this crap
I have to respectfully disagree on what
basis he's getting more money if you put
it somewhere else
but he's able to borrow against this
if you've got 25 million in mutual funds
you can borrow against it but he's he's
going to have to wait until he's you
know to get that amount of money okay so
you're going to teach him that the way
he becomes wealthy is borrowing against
money that his father invested for him
that's how he builds wealth
said no one rich ever
I mean Banks use this product to no they
do not you've been watching too much
Tick Tock Banks do not use whole life
not ever
thanks nowhere
I would respectfully disagree no they
don't
they do not use whole life life
insurance what bank well I mean we we
could Google it and see what typically
Banks do with their money but um I I
believe typically Banks never put money
let me tell you what banks do they put
it in bonds they're required to they
wouldn't be allowed by federal
regulations
hmm it's not a place to invest money
because it's a horrible investment the
rate of return sucks and when you die
you lose your cash value I know but but
you also
you don't
you're making it sound like I'm losing
money on the whole you are you're
leaving money on the table you're making
it sound like when not me but my son
when he dies yeah that he's only going
to be able to get his he's going to have
22 million dollars less than he should
have if you had put this in a good
investment
you had mentioned that the cash value
guys and you only get the face value
that's not true that is true that's not
I just I just covered that with you for
the last 10 minutes paid up additions
are the only way that cash value
increases unless you're using a
Universal Life program B where you pay
extra to get the extra insurance which
is another form of paid up additions
that hasn't come out of my pocket though
I put 70. it is coming out of your
pocket it's coming out of the policies
pocket I know the policy you put the
money in dude and then it paid you a
dividend and you chose to buy more of
this crap with the dividend and you're
calling that I kept my cash value no you
didn't you bought more insurance
well I know that I put in 70 000 and and
at a certain age it's going to be at age
when he's 15 years old that's going to
be paid up yeah Jim and you understand
what paid up is you understand if you're
alive that there's a probability of your
death and so 100 of the time that a life
insurance program is paid up it means
that you prepaid it that's all it means
because as long as there's a probability
of death there's a cost so the insurance
company has always got a cost as long as
you're alive so there is no such thing
as a paid up that's a that's an industry
term that gets suckers like you that's
what it is now paid up means prepaid you
paid all of the premiums in 13 years for
his whole freaking life in advance
that's why it's paid up hey man I think
you ought to keep it it's perfect for
you but thanks for the call
thank you
hey what's up guys it's Jade if you love
the show and want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions it's the Ramsay show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships Jade wash all Ramsay
personality is my co-host today as we
answer your questions about your life
and your money open funds at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
that's triple eight eight two five five
two two five
KC starts off this hour in Charlotte
North Carolina hi Casey how are you what
are you guys doing better than I deserve
what's up
so I'm a uh Army recruiter and I recruit
for active duty in the reserve thank you
and uh thank you I appreciate it but um
when I talk to kids about active duty
it's easy when we're talking about
college because the arm will just pay
100 tuition and give them a paycheck
absolutely
but when I talk about the reserve it
gets a bit more complicated and part of
the incentive for the reserve is that we
have a student loan repayment up to like
fifty thousand dollars and I don't know
what advice to give to these young men
and women when I'm sitting down with
them so right now I'm telling them hey
take out this student loan and the Army
will pay it back for you but put it in a
CD and keep it safe and then use it as
like uh I'm getting out of the army
bonus after it's been paid off but I
don't know if that's good advice because
I don't like to give advice yeah that
says hey take on debt and I don't know
what else to tell them because it's free
money for them I appreciate that
um the um well that'll work only if it
works
and you know you're asking an 18 year
old to be smart
um and you're you're in the Army you
know better right and a lot of times
it's a I sit down with the parents and
yeah I know
you know what I'm you know what I'm
saying and so uh yeah now the uh we do
some work with the Air National Guard
and the Army National Guard both and
they have a ten thousand dollar uh
tuition program does the reserves not
have that too
so we do
um we if we actually have this uh four
thousand dollars a year of tuition
assistance and we also have a monthly
stipend that goes up to a thousand
dollars a month as well and that's has
nothing else added to or like about a
thousand dollars a month that stipend's
just a reserve stipend that's not for
Education only right
no that's that's for Education only oh
really and they also have their regular
paycheck as well okay so they got the
regular paycheck and they get a thousand
dollars a month if they want to go to
school stipend and four thousand dollar
reimbursement
it's a four thousand dollar tuition
assistance they pay the school directly
up to four thousand dollars a year per
year for a per year and the twelve
thousand dollars goes how long
how long can you get the thousand
dollars how many years
as long as you're getting your your
first degree
okay so you could do four years which
would be forty eight thousand and you
could do four times so sixteen thousand
yeah
well it'll be um yeah they only get the
paycheck while they're in school the
extra thousand a month while they're in
school so in the summertime they don't
get that pay
okay oh so it's not a full 12 000 a year
all right so it would be nine thousand
dollars a year so yeah yeah so we call
that thirty eight thousand right or
thirty seven thousand and thirty six
thousand I'm sorry and the um and then
we get sixteen thousand on top of that
which is the four years of four thousand
correct that's more than fifty thousand
dude
right I'm just and they don't have to
take out the loan
okay I just like to give them as much
money as I can I I appreciate that I I
would not ask them to step up on the uh
so here's here's here's my principle
number one I don't borrow money you know
that principle you knew that for your
call and again thank you for your uh
service and for what you do okay but
want the principal the other principle
it's violating for me uh is
um
the uh uh okay almost every time that
you borrow money it only works if it
works
and life doesn't always work and so
you've got this plan I'm going to open a
business and I'm gonna borrow ten
thousand dollars and I'm gonna make a
hundred thousand dollars until you fall
off the tractor break your hip and you
lose everything and now you've just got
the debt and you don't have the business
okay or until you know it works if I buy
a car on payments until I lose my job
and I can't pay the payments and it gets
repoed it works if I they do this until
until until it only works if it works
and in our minds when we analyze using
debt it we only analyze the if it works
part not if it doesn't work part the
risk part and uh the second thing that I
another principle we use around here is
uh I like to put my life on wise
autopilot and avoid stupid autopilot
autopilot mean that it automatically is
going to be smart even if I leave it
alone
and I don't have to assume that an 18
year old suddenly is going to be with
the help of his parents or without wise
and keeping control until he's 25 and
not screw this up
I mean you're just asking for trouble
here
and you've been I mean you recruit these
guys every day
I know I just trying to give him the
best advice I can I know but I'm just
saying I'm going to say if they get if
they take the money out or not because
I'm not going to ask kind of with or
without me you know I've done youth
ministry and I'm not going to ask those
people at that age with that level of
brain development
to take on the level of discipline and
leave their hands off of this and not go
to Hawaii with their girlfriend
using this money I'm just not going to
ask them to do that because it's going
to get screwed up it'll never happen you
know it's going to get screwed up so I
would I would man I think you guys got a
great program with the stipend I knew
there was about 10 grand like like there
was like the like the National Guard has
but I didn't know exactly where so 12
000 No 9 000 if you take the summer off
but if you if you go to school all
summer do you get the stipend still
if you went to school 12 months a year
for four years you'd get 48 000 bucks
plus the 4K
maximum is 36 months oh okay
it does max out at four years on nine
months then okay
so you might as well not okay so we'll
we'll do the four years of nine months
get the thirty six thousand I'll get the
sixteen thousand reimbursement as well
and
um and so that puts me at what fifty two
thousand bucks right
yes sir yeah and that's a great benefit
a kid that doesn't is trying to figure
out a way to go to college you can go to
college by joining the reserves make
things still get FAFSA and they can
still get all the other scholarships
yeah we just we just gave you a great
commercial
I appreciate that but I do I believe in
it I mean we endorse the National Guard
in the Air National Guard both they're
some of our sponsors on different things
because of this subject this is the
reason they come to us and the reason we
like to endorse them is because we
freaking hate student loans and you do
too Casey you're a good man thank you so
he's got a great heart he wants you to
make sure these kids get all they can
get yeah I mean but I I
wouldn't I wouldn't go with the risk on
the on the loan no you can't you can't
trust 18 year olds to
and I was a little nerd me too I was a
goody two shoes and I would have I
wasn't good at two shoes but I was a
math nerd and I was I was always trying
to scheme a scam figure out a way to
make it work I would have been the guy
that did that yeah and then I would have
been the guy went to Hawaii too I was
gonna say I would have had a new purse
in Hawaii yeah that's it well I wouldn't
have had a purse but there's that thank
God yeah that was long that was long ago
there were no merces in those days
oh my goodness gracious help us Jesus
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
here
hey folks Dr John deloney here with some
great news you get to choose whatever
you do good or bad moving forward the
choice is yours and when you're
intentional about making good choices
over time they become Healthy Habits
Like choosing to slow down and make time
for a daily practice of prayer
meditation one thing that has helped me
with the daily practice of meditation
and prayer is hallow hallow is the
number one Prayer app in the world and
they're giving you three months free to
get started that's three months free to
prioritize your mental health and be
intentional about finding peace through
calming music prayers meditation and
more and hallow isn't just Catholic you
can tailor the content towards your
faith tradition if you don't have a
faith tradition this is a great place to
learn more about it from scripture
readings and prayers to journaling
hallow makes it easy to practice
mindfulness build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and choose
peace remember hallow is giving you 90
days free imagine the peaceful habits
you can establish in 90 days go to
hallow.com Ramsay today and follow the
simple prompts to start your free 90-day
trial that's hallow.com Ramsay
foreign
[Music]
personality is my co-host today Landon
is in South Bend Indiana hey Landon
welcome to the Ramsey Show
how you doing great how can we help
hey
um so I'm a new home buyer or a
homeowner and
I just uh I did get it financed and I'm
basically in a situation where the money
that I make I am spending on my bills
and paying for mortgage and I am just
curious
um what is the best way to get to
Financial Freedom from where I'm at
it sounds like you maybe bought too much
house and you don't have margin is that
what I'm hearing
well
um basically long story short uh I was
renting from my employer
um which is also my brother-in-law and
I'm sorry that sounds like a horrible
situation but keep going well it's it's
not a horrible situation but um
basically they offered to finance a
house for me because I wanted to put
that money towards a house versus just
renting
and so they
um I didn't have anything to put down so
they financed it 100
um and it's at seven percent
um interest
um so the payment I was able
the payment's Eleven Hundred and how
much do you make every month
uh right now my bring home is 36. yeah
yeah you're gonna feel that
yeah
you can feel it
so yeah
here's what we need to do if we need if
we're going to make this work long term
because it's in the house is still in
your name right they just gave you the
money for the down payment right
correct okay if you're gonna make this
work long haul we need to get this to
where it's no more than 25 percent right
just so you can breathe do you have any
other debt
um I have about three thousand dollars I
owe on my truck and that is through them
as well but that is interest-free
why do you keep borrowing money through
your workplace
um like I said it's family and they were
just trying to help me
um get basically a leg up and get
um
get started I was in a bad situation how
old are you Linda
22. what do you do for a living
[Music]
I'm a maintenance manager at their
theater okay all right
um they are trying to do a nice thing
for you but they have done it in such a
way that it is a curse and not a
blessing
[Music]
because you called because you can't
breathe
right
and you owe all this money to your
brother-in-law who also is your employer
and so if you screw up uh making a
payment it affects your job if you screw
up your job it affects whether you keep
your truck
you're walking around carrying three or
four hundred pounds on your back all day
long trying to breathe I'm so sorry and
again I don't think they did this to
harm you they were trying to be helpful
but but sir you you have you have a
curse on you yeah and so um and the
reason let's just get this going moving
forward the reason that you had to
borrow money for a truck is because you
couldn't afford a truck and the reason
that you had to borrow the money to buy
a house is because you couldn't afford
to buy a house you bought a house that
you really can't afford
um and uh you're 22 years old
and it's man I'm just my heart's hurting
for you right now because I mean you got
a lot of pressure on you man
and so
um uh now the house was theirs and they
sold it to you right
no it was
um actually a private sale oh you
wouldn't they went and bought a house or
you went they went they gave you the
cash to go buy a house and they financed
the whole thing
yeah oh okay so what do you owe on this
house
um right now I owe right around I think
it's 58 158 000. okay all right do you
have any uh when did you buy it
uh I bought it and
um
I guess I would have bought it in May
what do you think it's worth
for
uh in appraisals for 180.
sell it
okay
dude you can't breathe
let me ask a question
I have a question about this if you turn
around and sell this house are you
worried about what they're gonna think
that you just used them to get this
house so that you could turn a profit
not not really just that I mean I'm not
I would be lying if I said that wasn't
on my mind
um I would go in and sit down with your
brother-in-law and say I I made a
mistake I can't pay this payment and the
truck payment on my income I can't
breathe the stress is killing me I'm
gonna sell the house and I don't want
you to think I'm doing it because that's
true and I don't want you to think I'm
ungrateful I am not ungrateful and I
didn't trick you I can't breathe and I'm
putting the house on the market that's
what I was with the conversation I don't
think you're going to do that because I
don't think you're in as much pain as I
think you should be well if he can if he
can find a thousand extra dollars a
month if he can find a way to
permanently get his income up get rid of
this truck payment he might be able to
he would be able to continue on
considering that's his only debt we
didn't get further far enough into it
let me just tell you
it's a bad idea to owe your house
payment to your employer oh who's also
your brother it's a bad idea to owe your
house payment to your brother-in-law
it is a triple X bad idea to owe it to
your brother-in-law who is your employer
man there's so many things that can go
wrong with this that have lifetime
implications Thanksgiving dinner time a
blessing and again I don't think he's a
the brother-in-law's a bad guy I think
he's just dumb
and he was trying to do a nice thing in
a and he did it in a dumb way without
thinking about he he made the assumption
that this young man needs to own a house
and he's wasting money when he's renting
and we're going to get him a house and
we did him a favor and that's what's
going through this guy's mind but he's
wrong he made a mistake I mean it's the
equivalent all of that co-signing I'm
gonna buy my kids a house all these
things I'm going to buy land and then
the kids can live on the house all those
ideas where you're you're
um you're trying to manipulate someone
else's financial situation they can't
afford it that's why they don't have it
and if you don't the reason your
grandson needs a co-signer for the
Raptor is because he's too broke to buy
a wrap he can't afford it hello yeah
this is not hard and Landon that's you
you're too broke to have bought this
house you shouldn't have bought it and
you bought a house you can't afford it's
not a super expensive house and it
sounds like the good news is you can get
out of it and with your skin intact
um I don't think you're gonna sell it
though I'm talking to you yeah he's 22
he doesn't need to have a brand new
house and a brand new truck or or a used
house in a used truck yeah and it's okay
it's um I I would get the truck pay I
sell the house I'd pay off the truck and
I'd start piling up money and I start
working on my career goals and what am I
going to be when I'm 32. yeah and what
am I going to be doing that I make 60 80
100 000 when I'm 32 and and because you
don't want to be doing exactly the same
thing no matter what you're doing when
you're 22 when you're 32. so the way he
has that conversation though is key down
you got to go in there just play the
cards say what happened but if you got
to believe that too I'm not sure he
believes that no I yeah I don't know
that he believes it's the right answer
but he did say it was bothering him look
if I I if I was a certain type of person
and I said hey I'm going to help you get
in this house I would never do that but
I could see how they might go oh
you just wanted us to flip this house
for you yeah
yeah I think it's okay to say out loud
this is yeah I'm scared to death and
um and does and they don't get to talk
you out of it you're still going to sell
it right but you just let them know two
problems or you know one is uh two
things I didn't buy it to flip and and
two is I'm not ungrateful but the reason
I'm selling it is I'm so scared I can't
I'm scared spitless and this is killing
me I'm carrying 300 pounds around on my
back yeah that's connected to my job and
my family yeah exactly exactly which is
like a triple X reason not to do that oh
my gosh extra large extra extra extra
large problem a triple X problem Rick's
in the backpack extra large
tree extra large this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
hey guys being free to make your own
medical decisions is a big deal these
days Christian Healthcare Ministries
gives members the freedom to choose the
doctors and providers they want without
the frustration of worrying about
networks and with no waiting period to
join it's a membership-based non-profit
Ministry where hundreds of thousands of
Christians share funds to pay for and
pray for each other's medical bills for
over 40 years chm has helped families
living across all 50 states so cfchm
could be right for your family check out
more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
thank you
thank you for joining us America Jade
warshaw Ramsey personality is my co-host
today open phones at triple eight eight
two five five two two five she and
Rachel Cruz and I will be co-hosting
each other or whatever you call it all
together on a live stream this coming
Tuesday
and that is September the 12th at 7 pm
central time it is completely free it is
student loan debt in America how we got
here and how to get out there is a lot
of extremely bogus programs coming out
of Washington right now that are really
misleading and scary and
um we we want to not just beat up on
Washington although that's a lot of fun
but aside from that we what we really
want to do is just show you guys some
hope some actual facts of people that
got out Jade got out of 260 280 280 000.
I keep trying to call it 260. don't
don't short Change me change that 20.
all right 280 000 she and Sam worked
their tail ends off 465 000 total in
debt that they cleared up it took them a
long time it took them seven years yeah
it's not going to take you guys that
long because most of you a don't have
465 475 000 in debt B
um you you know you probably are in a
different place than they were when they
started this so there's a whole story
there she's going to tell you that story
but we're also going to just show you
story after story after Story of people
who did just like you
single moms people who
lost their job people who couldn't get a
job in their career field and they still
figured out a way to do this and we'll
help you we're going to show you how I
know it's confusing I know it's scary
and so sign up go to ramseysolutions.com
student loans sign up for the free live
stream it is this coming Tuesday night
do not miss it it's free what do you got
to lose
your student loans oh
that was an underhand pitch it was
Tiffany is with us from Chicago hi
Tiffany how are you
I'm good how are you better than we
deserve how can we help
I have a question about my car I am
upside down in my car loan but it is my
only primary uh source of transportation
and I have two children that I have to
take care of so I don't know what to do
you single
I am okay
how much is the car worth
um the car is worth five thousand
dollars no give or take a couple hundred
um and the car loan is 20 grand
what how in the world wow how'd you get
so far upside down
um well when I bought the car it uh was
added like one of those like Buy Here
Pay Here shops and I really just needed
a car because I had to get back and
forth to work and take care of the kids
so you got screwed pretty much pretty
much I now know that now like a year
after I paid for it or I'm paying for it
so you overpaid for it did you trade a
car that had negative equity into it no
wow you just really overpaid you you
overpaid you overpaid ten thousand
dollars
yes really
yes I did I I really was on um I wasn't
I wasn't knowledgeable enough to know
what I was getting myself into and I
like I said I just really did okay let
me let me stop your second is the note
still at the poked a note lot
yes okay the payment that the payoff
they're giving you is not the payoff
okay that's what's called there's two
ways to calculate a rip-off car loan
okay and this is a rip-off car loan no
doubt about it okay subprime lending
what what one way they calculated they
you ask them what what's your loan
balance and the way they keep the loan
balance on the books is called top total
of payments which is a total of all your
payments over the whole time including
the ridiculous Bud interest rate that
they're charging you that is twenty
thousand
okay you do not owe twenty thousand
dollars on the car though that's just if
you pay every payment and add them all
together
interesting okay that's a top
calculation and that's the account
balance that is different than the
payoff balance in a sub now in a regular
car loan they're the same thing the
payoff and the account are the same
thing they just keep your account
balance your principal balance is all
they give you but on a rip-off loan on a
subprime loan they'll put it on the
balance on the books as a top and what
that does is it it takes all your hope
away and you feel stuck which is why you
called so the good news is is the payoff
on that car is what's the interest rate
17 15.
um I think it's like 23. yeah okay good
good yeah okay so the great that's even
better news because that means that the
20 includes all that
okay so that tells me the payoff on this
car is probably closer to 10.
really yeah
yeah so if you just call them and say I
want to know so how bad your credit
uh it's pretty bad pretty bad it's like
horrible High fours
they couldn't be any worse okay yeah and
so uh your single mom what do you make
um I bring home probably like 3 100 a
month
what do you do
um I'm a retail supervisor how old your
babies
um my son is going to be 12 tomorrow and
uh my baby is nine months
who watches the baby during the day
um they go between my mother and uh
their father okay
okay so do you have any other debt
besides this car
yes can you look can you go through that
um I have Pro probably maybe about six
thousand dollars in credit card loan or
credit cards I have um about 73 000 in
student loans and I probably have about
five thousand dollars in um
uh regular loans and then I probably
have I think another 13 000 in a car
that I totaled
oh no insurance yeah no insurance hey
what's your degree in
um I didn't even graduate okay I just
kind of floated through school and then
how old are you ended up having a baby I
am 33. okay
all right girlfriend
we do have a mess and
um everything you told me it told us in
that list adds up to chaos
absolutely there's a lot of Chaos in
your life and there has been for an
extended period of time
in order to clean up the finances we
also have to clean up the chaos
yeah because the chaos is causing you to
feel desperate and stuck and right after
I get desperate I get stupid
and so have you a time or two
yes you feel stuck and desperate and you
go to a car and Tote The Note lot and
get ripped off because you didn't feel
like there's anything else you could do
because you're desperate
right yeah okay all right so we got to
calm down back up and say all right
couple things we're number one
uh Tiffany one of the things I
discovered because I grew up without any
money did you grow up without money
yes yeah and I found out that rich
people think different
they think
every time they make a decision how does
this affect me 10 years from today
when I grew up we thought about how
Friday was going to be
exactly Thank God It's Friday oh God
it's Monday
right and we turned up the music about
four o'clock Friday afternoon and tried
to forget that Monday was coming
and that makes you broke when your
planning window is short you make Dumber
decisions than if you have a long-term
planning window rich people think when
they buy a car how's this going to play
out in 10 years you thought I got to get
to work tomorrow
exactly and so what I want you to do
slow down is with every decision you
make from the day forward about money
and about your career I want you to
think about 42 year old Tiffany and how
she's going to like this version of
Tiffany that's 32. okay
so we're going to think like rich people
we're going to think long term and then
it that'll draw you up out of the mud of
the chaos slowly
this is going to be slowly does that
make sense absolutely okay so let's do
two steps
that I can think of and then you jump in
okay I gotta get these out of my system
before number one uh I want to do I'm
out of time
go ahead hang on hang on through the
break hang on through the break can you
because you you need some help girl we
can't just dump you into a commercial
break so you hang on we're gonna come
back and give you some actual uh
marching orders okay
okay thank you we'll be right back this
is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees
everything's backed by their 100 percent
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free
see whyblinds.com is the number one
online retailer of custom window
coverings visit blind
com to get up to
rules and restrictions May apply
[Music]
[Applause]
Jade wash all Ramsey personality is my
co-host today we're talking with Tiffany
in Chicago she has a nine month old 12
month old she'd make it 3 100 a month
she she has a car that is valued at
about five thousand we think the payoff
is around ten thousand with a Tote The
Note lot she's got a lot of other
miscellaneous debts and uh has had and
we established early a lot of chaos
and disorganization in her process and
we're discussing what her next steps are
so Jade I'll let you jump in yeah I
think right now obviously we've got a
bit of an income problem and I want to
try to find where where we can find some
of this money so my first question to
you Tiffany is what's your living
situation are you living with anybody is
anyone living with you tell me about
that
oh well let me try that picking up the
line that'll help okay now go ahead
Tiffany
oh I'm sorry it was our fault I didn't
pick up the line uh can you hear me yes
ma'am we can now oh okay I was like
what's happening
so yeah I live alone um it's just me and
my kids and I rent
um and my rent's probably like twelve
hundred dollars so good
um
so 1200 rent um I want to know are you
getting a tax return every year
um
a little bit I I've adjusted that uh to
not get one because I have been uh
trying to get out of this mess since
I've known it that it was a mess and I
kind of listened a lot to Dave Ramsey
and I bought the total Total Money
Makeover and I was like oh my gosh this
is such a light to my eyes and I feel so
much less stressed so I have adjusted
that uh to make sure I do get if I do
get anything it's very minimal so I can
make sure I can pay my bills and how
many hours a week are you working
I work um 80 and if they offer over time
I am the first one to volunteer
um but at 40 and I know you've got the
kids it sounds like you've got some
family in the area that'll help you you
got it at this point it's an equation
right we got it we gotta make a bigger
shovel because you have a big hole right
to fill up
um and that's gonna look like you
looking for employment that at the core
earns more right so I want you to I want
you to start you know
beefing up the resume I want you to
start looking for jobs that you can
transfer your skill set and so before we
get off the line we're going to get you
hooked up with Ken Coleman stuff I'm
sure you've seen it but we'll make sure
you have that because I want your core
income to be bigger uh when Sam and I
were paying off our debt when we started
we were making thirty thousand that is
unsustainable it we could do all the
side hustles in the world and it
wouldn't have made a difference so you
got to get the core income up and then
in the meantime while you're working
towards that you do need to side hustles
also Yeah so basically those two things
together will double your income on the
short term on the short term okay and
you can do that and then we can start
cleaning this up now you said you had a
repo debt of how much
um thirteen thousand okay and what was
the other debts other than the five
thousand on her the ten thousand on the
car
s um probably
probably another six
this is off the top of my head I'm sorry
um probably like another six in loans
um 73 in student loans
um I think that's it okay about a
hundred thousand so you're not paying on
the student loans yet you're not paying
on the 13 000 repo at this point are you
no good okay so you've only got the
credit cards and the other loan that
you're paying a little bit on we're
gonna cut up the credit cards you've
already probably done that after reading
total money so here's the thing I one of
the things I discovered I told you I
didn't grow up with money one of the
things I discovered was I could learn
from anybody about anything by reading
you read The Total Money Makeover and it
helped you agreed yes so if I stack
books on you right now will you read
them because I'm going to give you a
bunch of them if you'll do it
absolutely all right so we're going to
send you Ken Coleman's book from
paycheck to purpose we're also going to
set you up with his assessment to
because I want you to aim at a long-term
career right now we're going to get the
core income up and the shadow so like
Jade said but I want you to think about
who Tiffany's gonna be when she is 30
when she's 42 and what are you going to
be doing you're going to be an executive
sitting in an office corner office
somewhere smiling making 100 Grand doing
what I don't care
you go get go to code school I don't
care what you're going to do all right
but you figure that out all right then
the second thing I want you to do is I
want you to go to let me see here let me
get this up uh go to this go go to uh
listen to this podcast Craig groeschel
and the nut last name is
g-r-o-e-s-c-h-e-l he's a pastor he is a
leadership podcast the guest on the
podcast like three or four episodes back
was an African-American lady came from
where you are she's now the president of
the Dallas Mavs
oh my gosh and she was the CEO of at T
at one point she's a force to be
reckoned with I thoroughly enjoyed
listening to the podcast she was
inspiring to me and she will be to you
because I want her future I want her
situation to be your future okay okay I
want you thinking like that because I I
want you to break this cycle for your
nine month old and for your 12 year old
it stops with you okay okay and uh now
we're gonna give you Ken Coleman's book
paycheck to purpose I gave you the the
uh that to listen to now then I I the
first thing we can scratch money
together if I don't want you to pay
anything on student loans just don't pay
them right now forget them okay even
though they come up in October just
don't pay them just forget them don't do
the on-ramp though don't do anything
just ignore them no if you ignore them
it'll put you on the on-ramp and the
interest will accrue okay okay
yes and get into the 30 or whatever it
is it'll be zero it'll be zero for you
yeah and just don't don't you don't
worry about paying on the student loan
but pay the minimum you can get in the
same save program it's a horrible
program but we have a plan at the end
we're going to pay it off later but
right now I'm minimizing your outflow
because I need you to gather up a couple
thousand dollars for a car when you got
a couple thousand dollars for a car I
want you to walk in to this Tote The
Note dealer and tell them you talked to
um your financial counselor
who said that they should talk to you
about taking this car back with no
repossession
you've already paid enough on it give
them the keys have them sign a paper you
owe nothing don't give them the keys
unless you get this sign the title over
to them and wash your hands of this car
and walk away they will do that deal
because they do it every day it's their
whole game plan their business model is
overs priced cars over interest cars so
they take them back and resell them
it's how they function and so that
you've already paid enough on it they've
made profit on you and and if they say
we won't do that say my financial
counselor told me I should talk to an
attorney should I do that or do you guys
want to do this
because your financial counselor is me
and I just told you that
right okay so you see what we're doing
we're scaring them because the contract
that they have is probably bustable with
a lawyer but I don't want to spend money
on lawyer I just want to Bluff these
rednecks into taking the car back
okay and they take it back no repo and
no deficit they don't get anything on
you and then you go buy a two thousand
dollar car with cash
and not from there and not productive
cash not from them just go go find one
in the freaking Craigslist and it's a
garage sale car who cares okay we're
just it's a short-term thing we're gonna
get a better car in two years anyway
we're not gonna drive this car for very
long okay then you're gonna get the uh
the loan paid off and the credit cards
paid off and uh then we're gonna reach
over and do the same thing with that
student loan with that deficit on that
car that car repo you can settle that
thirteen thousand dollar debt for about
two or three thousand dollars if you
call them up with cash in your pocket
and say well I can settle this right now
I'm a single mom I'm I'm a bankruptcy
looking for a place to happen are you
guys sure you'd want this on the books
or do you want to take three grand a
settlement in full settlement in full is
your big word you use that with a with
the uh Tote The Note dealer when I give
you this car back it's settlement in
full and I want a statement of paper
showing that otherwise I got to go talk
to my attorney and I don't want to do
that please let's just take this deal
and be done with it same thing with
these guys with the repo okay so a
couple Grand here or there we got you a
car and got rid of most of your debt
right
this is pretty cool yeah I mean I'm
talking I'm talking this time next year
girl you have no debt
oh my gosh that would be amazing
that would be amazing it will be do you
understand what I just told you to do do
you have any questions about it I do not
I wrote everything down okay and you
call us back if you're in the middle of
this and you got a question I know
that's right and if you want me to call
the Tok to note guy I will give me a
call and if you need a lawyer if you
need a letter
because my brother's a lawyer I'll get
you one in two seconds girl that could
be fun that could be fun we're helping
her we're doing that we're going to turn
this around this ends with you this
breaks the cycle breaks with you Tiffany
and so hang on we're going to send you
every bit of that stuff this is the
Ramsey Show
thank you
Dave here you can find all of our shows
with the Ramsay Network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the Ramsay Network app in your
favorite app store today
foreign
[Music]
ERS of Ramsey Solutions it's the Ramsey
show where we help people build wealth
do work that they love and create actual
amazing relationships thank you for
joining us Jade Washoe Ramsay
personality is my co-host the phone
number is triple eight eight two five
five two two five that's triple eight
eight two five five two two five Karen
is in Denver to start this hour hi Karen
how are you
and great Dave and Jay thank you so much
for taking my call you're my two
favorite personalities so honored to be
here and also a little bit nervous well
thank you we won't tell the other ones
I might tell Ken we might tell Ken
Jaden I love your turn skinny fat
because I totally identify with that so
my financial aspect not so much food yes
ma'am
how can we help you um Dave I'm 62 and
uh debt free except for mortgages I do
have a rental property that's free and
clear and I know how you feel about
selling those to get out of debt
um if I sell this rental property I will
be close to debt free
but I owe the IRS when I sell that
property I've had it 20 years I owe the
IRS uh about 65 000.
so you've never really discussed kind of
um you know your thoughts on
how your desire for us to become debt
free relates to making that big payment
to the IRS are you still good with go
ahead sell that thing pay the IRS and be
done
probably
uh but you know I always just try to
figure out if there's another way to
skin a cat rather than give the
government money right my first goal the
reason I want anybody to be debt free
including me is it's the shortest
distance to wealth
right I get that instability so it's not
we don't what Dave wants doesn't really
matter but you know where does it take
you is what it what matters so let's get
you there you're 62. you owe what on
your current home
um I
I made another mistake I bought a
property where I'm going to retire
someday and I know that's not something
that you're fond of
um so but and I owe 395 on that
the house I live in I owe 40 on
and then the other rental property I
owe0 on it's free and clear okay the
house you owe 40 hours worth the cash
you owe 40 ohms worth what
uh it's about worth 425. okay and the
house that you owe 395 on is located
where
it's in California it's worth 800. okay
and no one and no one lives in it no one
lives in it uh yes it's it's rented oh
it's rented
yeah so you have two rental properties
one of them you intend to retire in
correct and when do you intend to retire
well depends on how you help me with
this question
it'll be partial retirement I'll never
completely retire I'm your age I don't
I'm not ready to retire just yet okay
that's fine I just I'm trying to figure
out the timing on this no I get it so
why California why Northern California
um actually I have family there and I
would like to be near a body of water
I've been landlocked my entire life and
I'm also tired of the cold okay so this
is um near the ocean
correct like Sonoma or something like
that oh that's nice wow
oh Southern I thought you said Northern
okay
still very nice okay I might have
because
I've become a little nervous that's okay
that's okay
um
is it your work is it your work that's
preventing you from what's that yeah
what's that I'm sorry go ahead I just
I'm Mike I'm looking at these numbers
I'm like okay you want to be in Southern
California you've got a rental that's
free and clear that you don't want to
pay the IRS debt on you've got a home
worth 40 000 or that you owe forty
thousand worth 425. you could sell wow
you could walk there that's what I'm
getting at no I'm I'm self-employed as a
realtor so oh yeah start a new business
yeah okay
all right
um
what's the rental worth
the one that I'm considering selling I
could probably sell it for
um 350 ish
so you've got a million dollars in
equity between these three
[Music]
right it's just the scrambled eggs
that's driving us nuts okay right and I
and I just and how did you come up with
a 65 000 gain did you have your tax
person calculate that with your adjusted
basis yeah yeah my CPA estimates about
that's about what I'll owe because I've
had it for 20 years
and then that and my income I guess
okay so the big okay concern number one
is debt free is the shortest distance to
wealth concern number two is when you
retire a paid for property is essential
to Stu that you live in is essential for
stability
because it's your largest item and if
you retire at 65 years old and you live
to 95 you've got 30 years of rent
increases you know this is a real estate
agent you do not want to be a renter for
the next 30 Years or a have a mortgage
you want a paid for piece of real estate
that you live in at retirement so these
are our goals so you're going to sell
this rental it's just a matter of when
correct I'm going to sell it regardless
because it's 40 years old and it's time
to go back to the universe so I would
end up buying like a little you're gonna
sell it and you're going to sell it when
you move to California and you're retire
and you sell the house you live in or
you're going to sell it now and reduce
the mortgage of the pay off the little
forty thousand dollar mortgage and
reduce the other mortgage finish that
California mortgage off when you retire
and sell the house you live in right
so it doesn't matter you're going to
sell this you're not going to keep it 25
years so you know it's just a matter of
when you pay the 65.
not if right
yeah well I mean I could 1031 exchange
it forever but I'm tired of tenants
toilets and trash quite frankly yeah and
I and I don't and I want your I want
your California house paid off and it's
not paid off with the sale of your
personal residence
correct so I gotta get there and so
since I got to get there I got to sell
the rental
now or when your return moved to
California I'm catching on now I'm still
I'm seeing the scrambled eggs okay so
yeah go ahead and sell it just because
you're going to sell it anyway
okay don't give it away there's no rush
there's no I was gonna say if you don't
pay off the 40 if you've got enough in
the bank to pay off your house
no not right at this moment you don't
have 40 000 bucks laying around
well I do but I can do it Uncle Sam
it's for Uncle Sam
it's your real estate
but you don't have you don't have any
you don't have any other non-retirement
Investments laying around you just knock
your house out
correct okay well the seller rental pay
off your house pay that pay the 65 throw
the rest of it at the California then
when you retire sell your house and pay
your house off in California
that ain't bad that gets us there yeah
took a minute it took a minute part of
me is like okay this first if she's
still got two years she could possibly
let it accumulate a little bit more
value for two years before she sells it
right before she goes to California
I mean it's it's not a lot but it I'm
just saying you know trying to get this
money
that would work too I she's tired of it
I'm tired she is tired of it
let it go
this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
thank you
Jade Washington Ramsay personality is my
co-host today hey guys if you want to
help us out we'd appreciate it
you know we provide this show as a
podcast as a YouTube show as a radio
show as a TBN show as a free service to
you guys and we appreciate you hanging
out with us we would also appreciate it
if you would click subscribe or click
follow
or share the show just by telling
someone about it or actually cut the
link out email it to your friend and go
Hey listen to this or if your particular
uh whether it's Spotify or apple or
whatever uh has you know Google Play if
they have a share feature just click the
share feature and you can share it uh
sometimes it's that easy sometimes it's
your listening on talk radio and you say
hey our local talk radio station has the
Ramsey Show however you share it we
appreciate it our question of the day is
brought to you by neighborly your hub
for Home Services when you need to make
repairs schedule routine maintenance or
find local help for Home Improvement
projects neighborly is your source for
Reliable home service providers in your
area go to neighborly.com to start your
search all right today's question comes
from Carolyn in Arizona she says when
you have a company match does that count
towards your 15 percent my husband's
work has a three percent match we invest
three percent of his gross into an RSP
which I believe is a Canadian 401k and
the lawyer contributes three percent
would you say that this is three a three
percent or a six percent contribution
towards our fifteen percent that was a
lot of numbers but basically she's
talking about you know we say in baby
step four that is the time that we want
you to start investing fifteen percent
of your gross income into your
retirement okay yeah at the core of this
question Carolyn is don't ask how little
can I invest because the more you invest
the more money you have ask how can I
invest more that's good don't try to
figure out a way to do less figure I
would do more and then here's the other
thing
um if you switch jobs you might get to a
job where there's no match or there's
less match you don't know what what the
future holds and so I think it's always
good to practice the muscle of investing
your 15 of your dollars yeah because the
the match and the pensions and all that
stuff are gravy
that's not that's not your money you
invest fifteen percent of your money
you'll become wealthy the other gravy
will add to it yeah that's gonna be
great and that that's the way to get at
this good job good job Nancy's in
Chicago hi Nancy welcome to the Ramsey
Show
hello taking thank you for taking my
call sure what's up
you know I want to know what you would
suggest a person would do after the U.S
switches to a digital currency
what should people do Who currently use
cash as a budgeting tool
um well the first thing is I'm going to
suggest you quit me reading so many
articles on the internet
because the US is not going to switch to
a hundred percent digital
that's that's the goal people that are
trying to sell gold
on Fox News commercials
that are telling you that
that because there's not the U.S here's
the thing Nancy the U.S is about 95
digital now
almost all of our transactions move a
digit from one account to another now
if you write a check it's a digit it's
not cash if you use a debit card it's a
digit not cash if you have direct
deposit from Social Security or direct
deposit from your work it's not cash
it's a digit those are all digital
transactions if you buy a house and you
wire money from your uh mutual fund to
your closing attorney it's a digit
almost if you buy a car these days I
bought a car that wired money to the
dealer it's a it's a digit I didn't walk
over there with a suitcase of cash and
so the vast majority of transactions
ninety something percent of them
probably not north of 95 percent in the
US are already digital but the is the US
going to do away with the Greenback and
not in my lifetime or yours
I sure hope you're right because I've
been worrying about
the person that can't have a credit card
because if I spend money just by swiping
it doesn't register with me and it'll
just evaporate I'm a person that has a
redneck emergency fund in my front
pocket it's a thousand bucks and 100
bills I've carried it most of my life in
my wallet and so I'm with you I'm a cash
dude and I'm not above walking up and
actually making somebody learn how to
make change for the first time at the
register all day and so um I'm that guy
so I'm right with you but I I truly
don't think we're going to do away with
currency and most of what you're reading
has a Fear Factor to get you to buy gold
or it is some kind of conspiracy theory
stuff on uh
bricks or any of these other things that
are going around just to make us worry
that the entire U.S economy is so
fragile that it's going to collapse
because Russia which isn't their economy
is hardly the size of Texas is is going
to do something Russia's not going to do
spit they don't have the muscle too they
can't even feed their own people and so
you know it just Nancy whatever it is
that you're reading that's causing you
to worry quit reading it
scary it is scary I you know I know
people have different
thoughts around all of that but then
there's parts of me that I think about
there's so many things that have
happened throughout history that we who
are used to those things we look at this
and go yeah it's just part of life but
as it was occurring people were probably
like oh my gosh this is crazy I mean
Cars the cars that we have today there
was a time where that wasn't a thing
flying airplanes like all those things
you could look back and go oh my gosh
there was a time when this wasn't a
thing and maybe who knows and the next
lifetime the Next Generation they will
live in a different sort of currency but
we already have we already are I mean
you think about when I was a kid we the
number of checks we wrote yeah you don't
do that anymore I I in the number of
times you write you see someone write a
check at the grocery store yeah yeah
today I don't do they even take they're
much more likely Sim using cash yeah but
my point is we've adapted and that's
that stuff is a slow burn and before you
know it you look up and you go oh yeah
we live lives our lives in a totally
different way
um yeah and I just think there's
something the innocent version the the
malevolent version uh the the
level I can't say it the evil version is
that there's a conspiracy that the U.S
is going to control the all the digits
and therefore they're going to control
your life well they already do
have all the digits yeah and they don't
control your life with those digits and
so so the question is not the digits
being allowed to control your life
digital money because when you use your
Apple phone or when you use a car a
credit card or a debit card or you
transfer money any other way uh ACH or
anything else it's all digits so when
you do that they already have all of
that that's all available and so and so
far they've not used that to steal our
freedoms no not you know but there's a
commercial I heard it the other day and
then I saw a different thing a write-up
that you know when the US goes digital
you are not going to do transactions and
if they want to cancel you because they
don't like your faith or they don't like
whatever they can just turn off your
ability to do business as if it's like
the the mark of the beast or something
in Revelation okay and it's just I'm
sorry folks I you know
this there may be a mark of the beast
someday but this one's not it there was
a whole thing going around for years
that the credit card was the mark of the
beach oh yeah you had to have a credit
card to do a transaction and then the
last one was with the factory quarantine
yeah they had the uh the the uh vaccine
passport yes that was going to be the
mark of the beast and at one point it
was when you're finished
with marks when your iPhone scans your
face to let you into the phone it's like
they're gonna scan your eyeball yeah and
that's gonna be yeah now they got your
eyeball
so I mean it's it's ever and just don't
get Rachel Nancy I'm glad you didn't
call When Rachel Cruz was here because
she's the conspiracy theorist
extraordinaire and um she would have
joined you in this but no we're I'm not
going to join you so I I'm gonna tell
you honey don't worry I'm not worried
I'm not worried I got big old piles of
cash and I'm not worried about it going
out of style
um like real actual greenbacks so there
we go
yeah you're gonna be fine you're gonna
be fine and uh and gold doesn't solve
this by the way because there's never
been a failed economy or a government
takeover when people exchanged gold bars
I'm gonna run down to Walmart with my
gold bar
since the economy failed and I'm gonna
get me some blue jeans
it's just not gonna happen boys and
girls not gonna happen Okay you can't
find a since the Roman Empire
a modern day economy in the last 400 300
years that used actual gold as a medium
of exchange exclusively so these guys
telling you to buy gold because that's
what one of the commercials was on the
digits yeah because Americans are going
digital and you need gold
it's the latest fear to buy gold crap
don't do it this is the Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
personality is my co-host today I'm Dave
Ramsey your host thank you for being
with us Kim is in Jacksonville Florida
hi Kim Welcome to the Ramsey Show
hi Dave hi Jade thank you so much for
taking my call and thank you for
eign
but my question is I sold my house I
downsized and bought a townhouse for me
and my daughters and I was only short
about sixteen thousand dollars so
instead of taking a mortgage I just took
a line of credit against my car since it
was a lowest lower interest rate and it
was only 16 000. so now I don't know
because it's my last debt should I
tackle this like it's baby step number
two and clear out my um emergency fund
or should I look at it like it's my
mortgage even though technically my
mortgage is paid for and uh continue on
the baby steps because I'm on baby step
four currently as I go that route
I would tackle it as baby step two what
do you have yeah because what else do
you own the car you tack the 16k to your
car that was awesome car was paid for
yeah the card was paid for so you're
only debt in the whole world is sixteen
thousand dollars do you have it do you
have it laying around anywhere
well it's in my savings account but
that's my oh actually only I borrowed 16
but now I've been paying it for the last
five months aggressively so I only owe
eleven thousand dollars how much is in
your emergency fund
17 000. pay it off today
and just step back up that savings yeah
I agree with Jade what's your income
okay
raised them up
so you'll aggressively rebuild the five
thousand six thousand back up to a good
emergency fund within just a couple of
months
okay that's what I was thinking I mean I
was ready I called the bank I asked my
lady I'm like hey I think I'm ready to
pay it off and then I thought well maybe
I should you know keep that emergency
and work at you know baby step number
four because I'm not at 15 right now
um so yeah that's what I wanted to call
I wanted to see if it was if it was uh
you know a little bit more money or
something I might slow down and make it
six or something but I I think it's
there's a tremendous amount to be said
for cleanliness
okay I like that this is just clean your
life is very clean your baby step seven
now we just rock and roll on the
Investments as soon as we get the
emergency fund done right
right get that in there because I'm only
at like four or five percent right now
with Investments so I have to I have to
work on that so you don't jack that as
high as you can possibly Jack it after
you get the house paid off the emergency
fund in place
okay okay all right thank you so very
much I appreciate it thank you we
appreciate you calling that was good
that was good she kind of just jumped
back a step she'll do two three and four
and on to the races not sure I would
have done it that way but now that we're
there that's the plan Jared is in
Minnesota hi Jared how are you
hey Dave
how can we help
yeah uh my wife and I
um are going to be expecting a baby in
March congratulations we are trying
thank you uh we are trying to find
something a little bit more suitable
um for living and with the high costs of
rent we were thinking about potentially
getting a house
um so that the mortgages uh usually
roughly about the same or a little less
do you guys have any debt
yeah I'm currently a student I'm in my
last year of school
um and I've had to pay my way through
and I'm about 61 in student loans and
then she had a car that she had bought
after she graduated
um a few years ago which is at 18.
what's your degree in
my degree is math education what are you
going to do teach
yep okay what what will a math teacher
make
um usually starting it depends on the
the school district anywhere from uh 40
to 50.
what about your wife
uh she currently makes 51. okay and
she's done with school salary
yeah she's done the school and she's
she's working currently and what is her
profession
uh art teacher so a couple of teachers
teachers okay um look uh congratulations
on the baby coming I'm excited for you
guys I want you to have a house I want
you to have all those things but I want
you to have them the right way so they
don't have you right
um so first first things first hey I'm
just gonna walk the baby steps on this
are you familiar with that at all
a little bit okay so this is going to be
the fastest as Dave would say the
cleanest way uh for you to not only pay
off your debt save up the money you need
and eventually build wealth so there's a
framework here
um and it it involves paying off your
debt first before purchasing a home and
the reason for that is a your income
right now is tied up in your Stu it's
going to be tied up in your student
loans it's tied up in your car
and we want to free that up so that
you're able to save the down payment you
want you're able to get the house that
you truly want right
make sense
yeah rent is a great deal
short term it's a horrible deal long
term
so I agree with you you don't want to do
it long term but short term you if you
buy a house with this much debt you have
to buy an extra bedroom for Sallie Mae
um
because you you know she's still living
with you and you need to kick the old
woman out before you buy a house because
it's going to strain you heat and air
will go out the water heater will go out
in the roof will leak the first week you
move in this house with a bunch of debt
don't do that you're gonna get yourself
in a pinch you're a broke college
student brand new married brand new baby
on the way you're at the broke end of
life yeah do you have anything it's the
most broke you'll ever be right now
it'll it'll be nothing but better from
here you know better incomes from here a
better situation from here so renting
for the next little while uh is the
babies don't take up much room they're
small and renting for a little while
while you guys get your mess cleaned up
that you've made and then have a solid
foundation to buy the home will be a
blessing for you and not a curse if
you'll do that it is not popular among
your friends for me to tell you that but
I don't really care what your friends
think they're broke and you don't want
to take Financial advice from broke
people so uh the the the the risk that
you are adding mathematically to your
life by adding a house to a new baby
into a big old pile of debt This spells
stress
anxiety problems in relationships don't
do it please keep your life calm and
simple get out both of you get a job
both of you work your tail off smile
about the time that we had to eat broke
people food and drive broke people cars
yeah and you'll remember that Sharon and
I had those days Jade and Sam had those
days when you're first getting married
that's the normal thing that's right and
by the way if you're sitting on a
chunk of money because you
have money from the wedding or money
from graduation but right at the debt
throw it at the debt clean it up list
your debts smallest to largest and dump
them in that area we'll give you a baby
gift Financial Peace University we're
going to give your baby a gift we're
going to teach his mama and daddy how to
handle money and if you'll follow the
stuff I teach you in the that and that
Rachel and George and deloney teach you
in Financial Peace University you will
become wealthy
if you don't follow it you will stump
your toe stumble and struggle and look
like most people looking good and broke
and buying crap you can't afford with
money you don't have to impress people
you don't even really like and so it is
a normal good dad
unction to go buy your new child a home
thank you for being a good dad but
you're going to resist that in order to
be a great dad that's right and a dad
that delays pleasure children do what
feels good adults devise a plan and
follow it so hang on we'll get you guys
signed up for Financial Peace University
and you two go through that together as
a young married couple it'll be the best
thing you've ever done I promise you and
if you don't I'll give you all your
money back oh wait a minute you didn't
pay for it so there you go I'll take
some of that money back
that was our old back in the day we had
Financial Peace University we had a
money back guarantee we said if you go
to all nine classes you won't want your
money back if you don't go to all nine
classes we won't give you your money
back but if you'll go to all nine
classes you won't ever ask for a refund
and never had a single person ask for a
refund so there you go good it's great
but um yeah you just got to prove
attendance and all nine classes and that
you hated it and that we ripped you off
nah nobody ever got mad at anybody for
getting them out of debt
that's right you're too much fun this is
the Ramsay show
[Music]
our scripture today James 1 4 let
perseverance finish its work so that you
may be mature and complete not lacking
anything
and Sullivan said people seldom see the
halting and painful steps by which the
most insignificant success is achieved
love it Gina is with us in San Antonio
hi Gina welcome to the Ramsay show
hi Dave thank you so much for having me
long time listener big fan
um so I have been married 19 years uh 55
years old I am going for a divorce we're
probably towards the end of
unfortunately a pretty contentious
divorce uh we have been blessed with a
lot of assets and a very good income
um and my question is you know because I
I was not in charge of our finances when
we were married my my former husband
handed all that and I have to say he did
a great job
um my question is what debt should I
prioritize to pay off once the divorce
is final
oh my I'm sorry
that's really hard
well a friend of mine that does divorce
counseling says that divorce turns a
marriage into a business transaction
and so first and foremost let me clarify
uh what you're going to end up with and
why
um are you who's taking the home
Primary Home has already been sold and
we've each already purchased new homes
okay good that's good news so that got
rid of that problem is there any Co debt
that both of you are on
yes sir we have three investment homes
that have 50 Equity we have a SBA loan
that we had to take out during covid of
150 000.
and
um we have a vehicle that we owe about
26 000 that my former husband will be
taking okay
the divorce court does not have the
power to remove you from those debts
it has the power to assign the debts to
one of you but if the let's say your
husband's taking the car it has your
name on the debt if he doesn't pay it it
comes back on you
okay so you have what's called a
contingent liability as if you co-signed
on those so all of those debts that you
mentioned are real concerning
uh because I got a feeling the SBA loan
is a business loan obviously and it's
he's probably running that business it
sounds like
we actually are both 50 50 owners on our
business we have a business together as
well so there's a lot of pieces it's a
big web which is why this has been going
on since January so what's happening
with the business who's going to end up
with it
well he's going to maintain that
business at LLC
um I we are in the same business uh in
the meetings and events business and we
each have our own clients he'll maintain
the LLC that's in existence and I will
establish a new one okay and you'll take
your clients and go on with your life
okay but the SBA loan is in both of your
names
yes sir now he's offered to take it the
debts but I don't know exactly
um how that like you said I'm not saying
the same thing it has your name on it he
can take it but if he doesn't refinance
it and get your name off of it it
doesn't pay it for some reason let's say
he gets in trouble in business or gets
an IRS lien or something that that even
he didn't see coming okay you're going
to end up holding the bag on these
investment properties this SBA loan in
this car if he's supposed to take them
unquote quote unquote so
um and divorce attorneys don't do a good
job of explaining that to people
so they oftentimes oftentimes just split
things up and they go well he's got the
car and I got this investment house and
he's still on the investment house that
you got you know and uh he's still got
you know if you screw it up he's he's
baked then so uh you said there's a lot
of assets yeah what kind of cash do you
guys have yeah really
well um so we we did make a um a nice
proceeds from the sale of our primary
home we split those that was about
328 000 each okay so those those monies
were um split and they were there's a
legal word for them partitioned okay so
normally the lawyers advise not to buy
new homes in the middle of a divorce
right community property but we signed
documents that the funds were
partitioned of that 328 000.
um the loan I re I was able to get by
just barely um only allowed me to put
down 140 000 so I still have the rest of
that cash untouched in a bank account
that I would like to put down towards my
current home I also received a large
inheritance unfortunately it's been a
heck of a couple of years both my
parents passed in the last two years
sorry about that yeah that's still
um I received an inheritance of 528 000
um and it's in a separate account as
well untouched it's just been sitting
there
um Let me let me let me propose
something really weird it may throw a
monkey wrench in the middle of your
negotiations
I would propose selling the three rental
houses paying off the SBA and paying off
the house and splitting the cash I love
that
paying off the car I'm sorry paying off
the car paying off the SBA loan getting
rid of the three rentals and then you
just walk away with a pile of cash he
walks away with a pile of cash
yeah because what would have been the
plan with the rentals well
I'm guessing you guys are getting ready
to split those up weren't you
yeah yeah now we keep dancing around
like how's this going to work and we can
only remove each other from title and
exactly that's what I'm talking about
you can get off a title but you can't
get off the mortgage same thing with the
stupid SBA loan you can go open your own
LLC but you're still on the stupid loan
for 175k
cleanliness here it is again yeah that's
been the and so I it's um yeah yeah I I
think you're both setting up a very sad
uh reason but you're both setting up a
new dream
you're you're 20 years from now future
is a completely different picture than
it was five years ago
right and it doesn't involve an SBA loan
and it doesn't involve him having a car
payment with your name on it and it
doesn't involve three rental houses
the only way I would keep those rental
properties is if you refinanced them and
got each other's names off of them
it's because it's gonna bite you I've
done I've done this for 30 years it's
gonna come back and bite you it may be
10 years it may be uh five years from
now you want to remarry and you all want
to do something and this stupid SBA loan
has got your name on it and it keeps you
you and your new husband from getting a
house
yeah this is gonna as long as you keep
all this around it's going to keep each
of you from having the fresh start that
you want yeah that you need it's your
best shot at healing is the complete
separation so I don't know if I can talk
you guys in the lawyers into this but
man if it was me I would want to be uh
you know shake the dust off my feet man
I'd want to be clear a couple stupid
rental houses to be done with the SBA
loan the car loan and him yeah that's
not and you get all the cat you get your
half of the cash net
hey it's kind of a no-brainer then the
only thing we got to split up 401ks or
whatever's laying out there there's
nothing else left y'all already split
the home
right right you're gonna end up walking
away with over a million dollars cash in
the debt-free house you're living in
well uh I would pay dust this house off
so that's my next question because yeah
yeah you pay that house off but you got
528 000 laying there now you could do
that and you've got another 200 000
almost laying there from the from the
partition and you got the equities from
the rentals I don't even know what they
are minus the debts I mean the prices of
the rentals minus the debts minus the
taxes due because of the sale minus the
SBA loan minus paying off his car and
then the only thing left is divide up
that cash in the 401ks against each
other that ain't bad
it's clean walking and if you want to
buy some rentals you know after you've
finished crying and being mad and all
the stuff that goes with this get her
own then go get you a rental later but
who you know you got plenty of money
you're you're both going to walk out of
this millionaires I'm guessing that's
what it sounds like
and uh I know you are for sure with the
inheritance uh and you know and you've
got a good client base you're confident
in your your career steps you know you
got a good solid place for healing and a
fresh start I'm so sorry yeah but man
that's a lot of loss I really wouldn't
try to keep my finances in the past
while I'm trying to live a future I
don't know why the lawyers wouldn't
suggest that are they just bozos they
don't take into consideration these
contingent liabilities because they
don't have to deal with it five years
from now I do when they come to me yeah
I got to deal with it when it screws up
and goes sideways
that puts us out of the Ramsey Show in
the books we'll be back with you before
you know it in the meantime remember
there's ultimately only one way to
financial peace and that's to walk daily
with the Prince of Peace Christ Jesus
[Music]
thank you
hey what's up guys it's Jade look if you
like what you heard in this episode and
want to know more about getting started
on the Ramsay baby steps go to
ramsesolutions.com and click the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started